I can't believe I agreed to do this.
I'm very hairy.
I have an extremely high pain tolerance.
Some people do this all the time, right? So it can't be that bad.
I'm pretty sure I'll be okay.
For as prevalent as bikini waxes seem to be, I have very little idea of what they actually are.
WOMAN: So, you're a first time waxer? MAN: Yes. WOMAN: You really kinda don't know, there's choices that you have.
I kinda want to do what I do with my normal haircut, which is like, a walk-in and I'm like, "Hey, just clean me up."
MAN: Can I get shapes? WOMAN: You can get shapes. MAN: Can I get a dragon? WOMAN: Uhh, no.
Come on in and then we'll get started.
I don't have any time for regrets, I'm here, I'm more naked than I'm used to being in public places.
I'm sure it's going to be fine. This is most the nervous I've been about anything in a very long time.
MAN: I'm sorry that you have to get so well acquainted with my.. my bits. WOMAN: No, it's fine.
I still just have this, like, fear of my skin coming up. *woman laughs*
Let's get going.
Ooh, that's warm.
Who was the first person to do this?
Take a breath... First piece.. Okay..
*screams and laughs*
MAN: Do it to it. WOMAN: Ready? MAN: Yep.
That wasn't bad at all.
WOMAN: Okay.. MAN: *screams*
Oooh.. cool.
It's a one-two punch of hot torture and then pulling torture. Aaah.
It's like a short tiny electric shock.
WOMAN: Don't cross your legs on me. You don't wanna get stuck together.
*grunt* Cool. Ooh, that one hurt.
Alright, lift your legs, we're gonna do your butt now... Just like that.
I feel like a baby.
MAN: This is going to be an interesting area. WOMAN: Yeah... MAN: OOoohhh!
Do it. Mm.
For this I'm going to just have you take a deep breath.
AAAARIANA GRANDE! *laughs* Shit... This is way worse than I'd thought it would be.
AAHHH
AH! Shit! There was a second one!
Eh, Not so bad.
Now I'm just sad.
MAN: All the girls said the butt would be the easiest. That was way worse. WOMAN: You guys are a little bit more sensitive in this area. MAN: Yeah, you're telling.
You know they say, beauty is pain.
Now hearing somebody say, "I'm going to get waxed..." I know it's the equivalent of somebody saying, "I'm going to go jump out of a one story building."
I feel poetic right now.
I feel like I'm gonna have a spring in my step. Like I'm gonna go just waltzing down the street.
It's a giant, big, significant thing that people do and a lot of people don't appreciate them enough for doing it.
WOMAN: No... Well hopefully now, you'll appreciate every woman who tells you, "Oh, I gotta go get waxed." MAN: I know!
WOMAN: And then hopefully you'll be like, "Yo, me too, let's go together. You do it, I do it. MAN: ...Maybe. *both laugh*
I'm still not sure how I feel about it.
I feel like I can run faster.
It's just so comfortable. It's like an unfurnished basement.
I recommend that all guys try this, if not to look sexier, but to understand what women have to go through.
It's like taking the regulator cap off a car, ya know? Everything is just, much freer and looser.